Okay, children. Now I want to review
the different sexual positions.
Who can tell me which sexual
positions we talked about
humans sucks you out. We've been
engaging in it since the dawn of time.
Why is something so hardware into our
DNA become a source of moral, ethical,
and religious taboo?
That's right.
Doggy style.
We went over pile driver [inaudible] pile,
driver position,
good coy
cultural anthropologists,
Ernest Becker speculates as six became
the source of moral taboo and restriction
because it taps us into our
most basic animal nature.
Humans learned to cope
with our own mortality by
embedding ourselves in cultural
symbolism.
We feel a strong desire to exist as
spiritual beings and these animalistic
behaviors threaten the very structure
we use to cope with our own mortality.
Even though we're out of the middle ages,
we're still feeling the ripple effect
of thousands of years of repressed
sexuality.
And the beginning, we were all fish, okay.
Swimming around in the water and then one
day a couple of fish had a retard baby.
So retard fish goes on and
make more retard babies.
And then that had a retard baby,
which was a monkey fish frog.
So there you go.
You're the retarded offspring of five
monkeys haven't butt sex with a fish.
Squirrel.
Congratulations.
We've had a lot of social
progress over the last 50 years.
We've evolved past the,
I love Lucy Macho man house.
My paradigm in the fifties in the sixties
and seventies men began to embrace the
long hair, colorful clothes
and a more carefree lifestyle.
Women were doing just the opposite.
There were magnifying their
inner masculine direction,
clarity of purpose and vision.
No masculine or feminine does
not mean male or female. Either.
Gender can take on both roles.
And in recent years we've become more
and more focused on being less rigid in
our gendered roles while are focused
on a quality has led to a lot of social
progress and no one is arguing
that equality is a bad thing.
We have reached a sort of 50 50
stage. Listen, uh, quality is great,
but our society has started to smooth
out our natural masculine and feminine
differences. And this has seeped
into most people's relationships.
Sexual similarities.
One of the major causes of unhappiness
and intimacy is led to social and
economic equality,
but also in sexual neutrality.
Bank accounts are balancing
ball passions are fizzling out.
The key to sexual attraction
is based on sexual polarity.
This is the force of passion that flows
between masculine and feminine polls.
The polls between people create the flow
of sexual feelings. If you want passion,
you need a rabbi Asher in a rabbit sheet.
Otherwise,
you have two buddies who
decided to rub genitals and bed.
There's a scale of sexual polarity that
everyone will fall into with most people
having either a more masculine or more
feminine pole with a minority of people
having a more neutral polarity
or androgynous sexual essence.
It is important to realize that masculine
or feminine isn't male or female,
either gender take on both roles,
but for simplicity sake,
we're going to focus on sexual
polarity between a man and a woman.
Real sexual attraction will come when
there was a natural arc and flow between
the two poles. As a generation
of men grow weaker and weaker,
thus having a kind of neutered
expression of their masculine core.
Women tend to have to express their
masculine energy more and more.
Ask any women actively dating in
the world right now and often?
Their biggest complaint will be
that men these days are soft,
pussies or unable to take
lead and take charge.
A new term has even been
coined for him in like this.
Knowing where you sit on this scale is
important because you will always find
yourself the most attracted
to your sexual reciprocal.
This is why people who are closer to the
androgynous part of the scale will be
attracted to other people
with a more neutral sexuality.
While extremely masculine men will often
be seen with extremely feminine women.
This strong arc between the two Poles is
where the most passion, drama, emotion,
love, hate, tears, and
joy are going to happen.
This is why every love story features
two people on opposite poles.
You rarely see a passionately
androgynous love story.
The bottom line up today's
50 50 relationship is this.
If we cling to a politically
correct sameness,
even in moments of intimacy than
sexual attraction disappears.
The love and friendship may still exist,
but sexual polarity fades
and true passion is dead.
We have a Roni slowly begun to deny,
smooth out and neutralize our
masculine and feminine differences.
Because of this, people often end up
denying their deepest core desires.
Women complain about men who are wimps.
They have no purpose, no direction,
and an inability to have a spine to
go for what they really want. In Life,
men complain about women who
are ball busters. We need rest.
The spirit is willing with the
flashes spongy and bruised,
so how do we inject that love,
passion and sexual polarity
back into our relationships?
It can only come from creating a focus
on emphasizing our masculine and feminine
traits instead of repressing them.
Be completely unapologetic falling what
you feel in the core of your being.
Masculine energy tends to be more logical,
more in their head.
The feminine is more emotional,
more in the moment because as a man,
you tend to become lost in
your thoughts and your goals.
One of the main gifts your women can
offer is getting you into your body into
the present moment.
The main gift the masculine can give is
to offer guidance out of her moods and
into openness.
If she feels unfulfilled,
you should be able to figure out
what is missing when she is upset.
Manual train logically,
figure out what the problem is and
then create a logical solution for it.
They will then get frustrated when
there is no logical reason for her being
upset. The Feminine is free to flow
with the emotions they feel in moment.
You cannot use the same problem solving
logic you use at work in a relationship.
Instead of trying to argue with her
logically, pick her up spinner around,
dance with her. Make her laugh.
Change her mood, not her mind.
Don't analyze what upset her.
Let her feel your love.
Almost every time she is upset it is
stemming from her feeling unloved.
Learn to enjoy her anger, her
tears, her silent hardness,
the full expression of her feminine core.
Learn how to crack her shell of
harness and get your love inside.
There was no difference between
entering your woman's feminine heart and
entering fully into the world.